foreign
I'm not going into sober October half
ass I'm definitely charging every one of
you mother just like I did last year
when you're doing 80 of your max heart
rate for a minute you get one point I
had 1100 points and I read the comments
and they weren't hurtful they were like
people concerned and I was like that's
how people are seeing me yeah that's not
how I want to be seen I want to be seen
like Nas it's been six years since Joe
Rogan Tom segora Bert Kreischer and Ari
shaffir all embarked on the first ever
sober October challenge in the fall of
2017. a decision that to this day has
not only changed their individual lives
For Better or Worse which we'll talk
about later in this video but also the
entire comedy Landscapes relationship
with health Diet alcohol and exercise
you're not done with drinking oh yeah I
would no I'm not talking to drinking I'm
gonna drink the rest of my life the
first ever sober October challenge
started on October 1st 2017. but back
then it went by a different name the
month of no drugs and alcohol coupled
with daily intense workouts used to be
called sober October Bert fittingly
named after the least healthy member of
the group Bert Kreischer Joe Tom and Ari
were all concerned about Bert
kreischer's drinking habits and weight
gain so they came up with a challenge
that would eliminate everyone's vices
for a month to act as an intervention of
sorts for Bert no drinking no drugs and
vigorous daily workouts that were
tracked closely by whoop bracelets all
in an effort to save their best friend's
life if we go back to the very
origination of it it was a friendly
intervention and that's how it started
is three friends caring for a fourth
friend and making sure that he didn't
die since the initial month of sobriety
the sober October challenge has taken on
a life of its own each and every year
Joe Tom Ari and Bert have raised the
stakes of competition amongst one
another enforcing punishments and upping
the intensity of every workout the
residual effects of sober October also
started to leak into the world of Comedy
fans with thousands of listeners
inspired to take part in the 31 day
challenge and make physical improvements
to their own lives but it doesn't end
with the fans in fact the enduring
Legacy of sobreak October mainly lies
within the comedy industry and the
comedians themselves you know I'm upset
I went to this place Olsteen olenstein
Danish Bakery to get chocolate buns for
the boys and nobody wants to eat the
chocolate buns anymore we're on a health
kick dude all comedians are healthy now
we're trying man but pimpy's back dude
pimpy's back on my side now he's ready
to have a bun why you bulking up I want
to try to bulk up now okay people have
been no not bulk up no you're not you're
gonna leave this journey that you're on
now no I'm not gonna look good I'm not
gonna leave the journey he eats between
1 and 1 30.
[Laughter]
what started off as three of Bird's best
friends begging him to lose weight has
effectively changed the mindset of
dozens of the top comics in the game
obviously we all know about Tom segura's
insane Health transformation but it
doesn't stop there today some of the
biggest names in comedy are all on the
new health bandwagon from Chris
DiStefano AKA Chrissy intermittent
fasting to H Foley from are you garbage
almost losing 100 pounds I lost like 40
pounds because the intermittent fasting
goes again rather I think it was John
Steinbeck that said now that you can't
be perfect go be great so or something
like that where it's like you're not
we're perfectionist it's like if I don't
have six-pack abs after three months of
working out I'm quitting you're down 50
50 pounds wow which is weird how that's
how fat I am you can't really tell that
much
this is also true but you know what I
mean yeah but here's the thing it's it's
gonna be it's gonna be even more
dramatic in in not that long from now I
hope so yeah you're gonna you're in a
little bit people are gonna be like well
you really lost weight and you're gonna
be like yeah just down a hundred and
they're like what the [__] I know yeah
that's incredible yeah the old days of
Wild Rock Star Comics like Sam Kinison
and Mitch Hedberg Living fast-paced
drug-fueled careers that were
romanticized to sound super fun and
pretty badass have now been replaced by
everyone's favorite comedians constantly
pushing healthy sustainable Lifestyles
it might sound kind of lame on paper but
in the grand scheme of things this
change inspired first by Joe Rogan
fearing for Bert kreischer's life all
those years ago has slowly become the
new industry standard comedians have
never been this dedicated to taking care
of their minds and bodies and it might
just go hand in hand with the recent
boom we've experienced over the last few
years of guys doing more Road dates
producing more content and making more
money than ever before one of the great
things about being challenged physically
is it's also mental the people that
don't understand that have never really
been challenged physically people that
think that physical challenges are just
like just physical it's just brute grunt
work it's not it's a emotional
intelligence it's understanding your
desire to quit and you know conquering
your inner [__] all that stuff is it's
mental it's playing out inside your head
and there's a mental strength that you
acquire from that that you can apply to
intellectual Pursuits with just two
weeks left before the month of October
the question on every comedy Fan's mind
is will the gang be getting back
together for round seven not only is it
entertaining for fans to get to watch
these guys go through this uniquely
brutal experience together every year
but typically sober October results in a
few amazing episodes of The Joe Rogan
Experience with Bert Tom Ari and Joe all
getting together on November 1st to
recap The Challenge and get [__] up
with almost zero built-in Talent
tolerance so far there's been no word
from any of these guys suggesting that
silver October is not happening but in
the same breath nobody has said it is
happening either Burke's been promising
a significant change in weight ahead of
his new tour but this topic is something
that he talks about on podcasts fairly
often at this point all four of these
guys are at completely different places
in their careers and it wouldn't really
surprise me if they planned on skipping
out on next month's tradition but if
that is the case hopefully we'll at
least get a group podcast soon to hear
the fellas recap old times and discuss
the decision not to run it back this
year or maybe it will be sober October
business as usual I guess we have to
wait and see guest spots from last week
The Joe Rogan Experience had on Brian
Simpson and Matt Rife two bears one cave
was Bert Tom Andrew huberman and Corey
Henry kill Tony this week was with are
you garbage the ayg fellas were also on
hey babe why Mage talked with Dan Soder
we might be drunk out on Ari shaffir and
Joe list Matt and Shane's secret podcast
had Colin Terrell on the show are you
garbage talked with garbage island Tom
takar was on the Honeydew taste buds
battled best friend prize Bill Bellamy
was a guest on Whiskey Ginger and
flagrant had on Shane Gillis Barack
Obama That's not the list
[Music]
[Laughter]
this past weekend with Theo Von had on
John verakee the Tim Dylan show was a
solo episode the blocks podcast had on
Terry Crews Matt Rife was on first date
take your shoes off hat on Tom Segura
Joe list and Adam Ferrara were on you
know what dude Whitney Cummings was a
guest on Christy chaos tigerbelly had on
RFK Jr and Cheryl Hines salvalcano was
on being Ian with Jordan Lewis Black
went on stavy's world and Dion Cole was
the guest on the Harland Highway before
we hear about new specials a quick word
from today's sponsor my bookie everybody
knows that football season is the best
time of year and this year it's getting
even better because of my bookie and
their no strings attached cash bonus
that all of you can access right now
when you use are linked to make an
account use promo code
jkwrld and you can receive up to 200 in
cash bonus instantly deposited to your
my bookie account this gun that's promo
code jkwrld to claim your cash bonus
it's almost like joke world but there's
no vowels whether it's college football
the NFL or some other sport you can bet
anything anytime anywhere only with my
bookie now back to the video as far as
new stand-up specials go that are either
out right now or coming out soon
Michelle wolf has a new three-part
series out on Netflix right now called
it's great to be here we also have new
specials out on YouTube right now from
Joe bartnick and Sarah tolmosh that are
both definitely worth a watch gas
digital also continued their run of
weekly specials last week we got 30
minutes with Colin Terrell followed by
30 minutes with Jordan Jensen which came
out this week we all can do it I pissed
men off I [__] I drive people crazy
I've been going through so many breakups
anybody else
let me go through a lot of break I'm
really difficult to date I'm a pain in
the ass I just uh it's not going to
balance there we didn't think that
through
cool I'm not gonna I'm gonna close it up
okay you're gonna be a water girl
just Chuck that at me whenever I need it
would you I'm gonna go like this I'm not
kidding they're laughing but I'm being
serious you're gonna check it right here
if you [__] up I'm Gonna Hurt You Like
My Mother hurts me okay thank you
it's okay you'll never be her son and
she's upset about it all right anyway
there's also a few spatulas that will be
coming out relatively soon salvokano
filmed his debut stand-up comedy special
this past weekend in Chicago at the Vic
Theater which is very exciting we'll be
sure to keep a close eye on a release
date there and Tuesdays with stories had
another Live Theater show full of
hilarious moments this time it took
place in Philadelphia and featured Joe
De Rosa and Umar Khan this is their
third live show in the past six months
Mark and Joe on stage in front of an
audience of Tuesdays with a great guest
panel is always a fantastic Vibe so be
sure to check that out if you're looking
for any extra comedy content this week
thank you so much for watching this
video and for the love of God please
subscribe
at joke world
and the world is wrld
[Music]